I grew up in Manhattan I grew up in New
York City starting a restaurant when I
was 13 literally just you know getting
bossed around saved up money went to
culinary school opened up the first
meatball shop in February 9th 2010 it
was a runaway success people in New York
City like balls my mornings are probably
my most treasured parts part of the day
because I get some exercise in and then
I sit and I have breakfast with my wife
I've always been into style in fashion
it's always been a huge part of my life
so I would say you know between loving
my wife style and fashion exercise and
nutrition that's really what makes up my
cure now I'm Michael chernow and these
are my ten essentials it's a number two
comment made by love attention it's like
the perfect mesh between a matte finish
and it's got a tiny bit of Sheen yeah
LaVette and chin shit's the bomb I feel
like a leather jacket is classic um you
know whenever you want to spice up a
t-shirt you could throw on one of these
bad boys
and um pop the collar there you go now
you're a freaking star
I have always on the prowl for a good
vintage t-shirt thing about vintage
shirts is that they're there they're
worn in they sit on your body as opposed
to like you having to break them in and
sweating them and all these things you
can't really match a vintage shirt these
are a pair of j.crew for eight four slim
fitting jeans I've had these for four or
five years once you get a pair that you
love you gotta stick them these are my
rain optic sunglasses that I I love I am
constantly on the go and you know I just
feel like it's always great to have a
pair of sunglasses um you know I work my
ass off it's nice to give my eyes a rest
in between cannot live without the
MacBook Air it's taken my backpack from
like 50 pounds with my old computer so
now I think this thing weighs like three
pounds
yeah and then this thing this thing
saves my aunt's meatball shop here stuff
that we've designed over the last few
years so this is the meatball shop hat I
wear this hat when I'm just kicking back
we moved to the meatball shop vans
I love these bands I wear these all the
time too when I'm kicking back the the
sort of hidden surprise of these
sneakers is the insole the meatballs for
the balls of your feet everything but
the kitchen sink salad and the salad is
a chef's selection of all the
Greenmarket sides I'm in a few additions
we've got lentils mushrooms onions
carrots celery I eat this meal seven
days a week
parsley walnut time 360 we're close
through to your Hormuz on cheese olive
oil love
running sneakers running is a huge part
of my life it's where some of my
greatest thinking is done I'm an
advocate for the Nike free running
sneaker but one of the reasons why I
love these sneakers is because you can
like squeeze them into anything
essential in my life more tide kick
boxing gloves more tie is actually a
huge component of my life because it
saved my life I was headed down a
terrible road a guy introduced me to
Muay Thai kickboxing and it literally
saved my life you ever seen me with
these things on you might want to get
out of the way ladies and gents you are
watching gqueues ten essentials be sure
to follow us on twitter tweet hashtag GQ
ten make sure to comment below like this
video if you'd like this just be so big
be a part of this thing this this is
awesome